un presidente de izquierdas por primera
vez en colombia es la estimación de la
última encuesta de invamer que incluso
señala que en una hipotética segunda
vuelta
gustavo petro también lideraría la
intención de voto a un mes de la primera
vuelta de la elección presidencial el
líder de izquierda recorre plazas de
todo el territorio colombiano abogan sus
discursos por reformas estructurales
[Música]
después que se agrega valor otra vez de
un proceso industrial
la pregunta que tendríamos que hacernos
es porque colombia el que produce el
maíz
sin embargo la diferencia se estrecha
cada vez más con federico gutiérrez el
candidato de la derecha ha subido 18
puntos en las encuestas por lo que para
muchos estamos ante un escenario similar
a 2018 cuando iván duque protagonizó una
remontada en los sondeos y terminó
superando a gustavo petro en la elección
no más división no más discursos de odio
y de lucha de clases si a la unidad de
colombia y si nos ponemos de acuerdo en
lo fundamental el centro representado
por sergio fajardo es el que más se
hunde ha perdido 18 5% de la intención
de voto por lo que en twitter hizo un
guiño a un posible pacto con el tercero
en las encuestas
el polémico candidato rodolfo hernández
son las estimaciones en una carrera
electoral que lleva meses al rojo vivo
después de que las elecciones
legislativas del 13 de marzo los
candidatos de izquierda derecha y centro
fuesen escogidos en una consulta por
delante semanas vibrantes hasta el 29 de
mayo cuando se revelara si las encuestas
están en lo cierto